Un jour de juillet, le sol a soudainement doublé dans un magasin de ramen appelé Neko Rahmen.
Un homme de grand héritage avec une expression terrifiante serait entré
Maintenant, ne vous tournez jamais vers la tribu structurelle
Un fugueur qui réclamait un menu a décidé de défier son pays et a choisi Pakupaku Ramen
Corps
Boîte de fortune
Parce que c'est une sauce croustillante ou très épicée, donc il n'y a pas beaucoup de gens qui ont le courage de l'essayer.
Est
Un homme se met à manger des nouilles ramen comme s'il combattait un vrai diable devant un client abasourdi
rizière
Et en quelques secondes, j'ai gagné la sauce du soir et la boutique et j'étais un miracle.
objectif Êtes-vous prêt à relever le défi d'exploser comme une tribu en fuite ?
tous les deux